تصوير المناظر الطبيعية هو حقًا لي
شغف
[موسيقى]
لذلك هذه الرحلة هي عائلة فريدة من نوعها
لوكاس واستكشاف الأماكن
مع ifna قم بتوصيلك بـ في بعض الأماكن
لا أحد أقل جهدًا في هرولنا معًا
فان مصور محترف و سكيب
هولندا "سمع أنه سينتهي
لورش عمل dockerfile والجولة المصورة
sl prince دليل لبعض المجلات
أصبح العمل أكثر مرونة
بقدر ما تسمعه عن العمل معها
طائر الفينش الإنجليزية اثنين من الاستيراد ثم صفير
في الشيء
اصطادها وتخطط لبلد جديد
الأزمة هي بسبب الاحتفاظ بها
أتحدى نفسي
أخي الصديق من حجر الزاوية و
هو معها في القش لهم وقبل ذلك
ساعة إيماك في الواقع تقريبًا أبدًا
سمعت عن هذا البلد
عند إجراء مثل هذا البحث عبر الإنترنت
أراد استكشافها
مكانة حميمة
سترة درب بيضاء مثيرة جدا للاهتمام
التعرف على مجيئك لأكون حقًا
السهول حيث يعيش زيت الراعي
كل ما أريد أن أرى الأماكن التي تقريبا لا
لقد كان أحد
فهل لدي توقيت للكوميديا ​​هم أنفسهم
دعونا يطلق النار عليه ذيله وطريقة درب التبانة
كنز
لذلك عادة ما يفعلون الكتف القديمة
بعض الطلقات بالطائرة بدون طيار
القيام ليلة بومة عرين الأخ
تصوير دي
the vang vieng و أو نحو ذلك في التحدي
البحث عن لقطات الجسم
هو هذا كيف خططت ومعا و
يتم إعدامه وتجرؤ على عض المهاجم
المكان وهذا يحافظ على بلدي اليونان stenden
هذا هو الشيء الحقيقي
قاتمة إلى wtf السيطرة لجعل
حتى في ثلاث سنوات قبل النوم احترس
هناك
انها نقية للمغني هو خارج إيه
لذا احتمالات قصوى ليلا في بعض الأحيان
النتيجة المباشرة ليست فقط الصورة لك
انظر هو التجربة الجوفاء التي التعب
وقع هذه الصورة
حتى في هذا البلد يمكنك حقا العثور عليها
الجمال في أي مكان
أخي السائق القديم وابحث عن
نافذة وإيقافها ثم هو ذلك الشون
بالنسبة لي وهي خاصة بالمكان
مثل هذا ليس الكثير من الناس
منقحة ولأن العرض كم هو جميل
قطعة يضعها وهذا هو بالتأكيد
يستحق الزيارة
هناك ضيافة وبيرة الدم الأحمر
ولاكوست السادة يطيرون
بك الأزرق في الوقت الذي يعيشون فيه
الجبال المجاورة بطبيعتها
لهم من المثير للاهتمام أن نرى كيف هؤلاء
الناس يعيشون
ما كان أكثر غضبًا حقًا في الصحافة
لديك خطوة زيت قليلا من
مناظر طبيعية تلتف في مكان واحد
تتيح لك الوديان الآن مشاهدة الجبال
netweave في أوروبا شيء تراه في
الهيمالايا
إلى هذا الحد في العثور على أشكال المناظر الطبيعية
مصور فوتوغرافي
للذهاب إلى هناك واستكشاف الجمال
من البلاد
[موسيقى]